this last summer october i got mollied
right before sober october started i'm
just gonna ask
how sick of talking about that are you
no i just started talking about it on
stage
oh okay okay i don't no one ever really
brings it up
hmm really yeah that's like uh
okay we talked about it on rogan and
everyone just kind of was like
they knew i wasn't it wasn't like it
wasn't super funny to me when it
happened like it wasn't like you'd
expect
you know comedian to be like dude that
was [ __ ] crazy right no no no
correction nobody in the nobody in the
[ __ ]
world would ever think that that was
fine for those people listening or don't
know
bert had uh comedian arie shafir over at
his house they were recording a podcast
bert's kids were [ __ ] home he had to
go to the airport shortly
like shortly after the podcast that very
same day
and they were like hey let's you know
let's have a couple drinks together
mellow
and so aries fear [ __ ] doses
burt's drink with [ __ ] molly's and
all of a sudden
bert's [ __ ] like uh having a an
intense
hardcore drug experience in front of his
[ __ ] kids
having to go to the airport to [ __ ]
get on an airplane [ __ ] rolling on
[ __ ] molly nobody thinks that's
[ __ ] cool
the guy on the flight next to me got the
best back massage ever
[Laughter]
no i just started talking about it
because uh uh rogan was like hey man you
can you should you you can talk about
that on stage and i was i
just was like ah right the implication
being that you thought that
i didn't know how to approach you i
don't know yeah [ __ ]
[ __ ] with ari and people just start
disliking him and then on time
and then on top of that his [ __ ]
thing with the kobe comments like and
then
i mean dude he goes hard in the paint i
guess
i was thinking about that we were
driving over to do this with you and i
was thinking about that like you know
where do i stand on on all that you know
like we're like i
i don't want to like pile on a whole
canceled culture like let's
like harm this guy and harm his
reputation i'm not i'm not out to
to do that i'm not the [ __ ] police
but
we're we're the one thing out of all
that like
i'm not gonna say oh it wasn't a joke it
wasn't funny like i mean that's just
subjective
what's not subjective for me and it's
about that being on brand thing
is him saying i was hacked oh
no no right yeah but no but that was
actually a joke
that was the joke was it was such a
horrible statement that he wrote oh
hey guys i was hacked and and then you
know i i'm definitely
not going to sit here and defend ari but
i i have in the past um
i think what [ __ ] him up was the video
if he had just left the tweet
the video what video is weird it's like
remember when right yeah you heard ray
rice hit his wife
and you're like oh he's and they've
dealt with it it's going to be fine
he'll be back next week
then they show you saw the video of
everybody his wife you're like oh that's
a little different
yeah like [ __ ] he [ __ ] hits
her hit her
he i've never been hit that hard in my
[ __ ] life
and then and so i think ari's video was
was videos so much worse than that
in that case and oddly enough but um are
you
the same thing about the irish hack
statement then then you go and put all
of your [ __ ] on private you lock it down
yeah he launched himself
same deal it's uh it you know there's
i don't think there's any right way to
deal with that what happened to him why
don't
he was going to he it's such a [ __ ] show
in in in all respects of like
i i don't know what that kind of
scrutiny is like to have that many
people
tweeting death threats and doxing me i
don't know what
what protocol is no one knows what
protocol that is so you're just making
decisions flying by the seat of your
pants
hoping they're right and even the
decisions that i offered him
in that time where i was like this is
what i think you should do
in retrospect we're wrong and and and
like i said
well i mean maybe he thinks so and so i
i know tom and i talked about it and we
you know said what we said on our
podcast and he was very upset by that
i listened to the whole thing like what
the [ __ ] does he want
i don't know man i really like you know
i think i thought you were pretty
pretty objective pretty fair yeah i
thought so too but you know
also in that time when he's upset he's
also going through all this
fear of his life and and being assaulted
and
so i'm sure he wasn't thinking clearly
you know during that time either but uh
but yeah and and and then i didn't want
to talk about the molly stuff because
it's right on the tails of this kobe
thing
and it's just like i felt like i was
piling on and joe's right right right
now man you can
d molly you're allowed to talk about
that on stage you know what bothered me
was that that this when it was i think
sober it was right before sober october
that he wanted that he dosed you
and it's you and it's segura and it's
arie shafir it's
broken all in the same [ __ ] room and
like the story comes out
i felt like uh i mean i
i was like pissed off for you in a way
that just
everyone was kind of like maybe because
he was in the room maybe because
i think it was i mean joe and i talked
after that
and he was like hey man i don't think i
me i'm not
i'm i don't like speaking for joe and i
don't like sharing private conversations
but i think i'm okay to say this
he was like i don't think the weight of
that hit me
when you told me on the podcast i don't
think i i don't think i
understood what how [ __ ] up that was i
wanted the weight to hit more
and that's scenario but i don't want to
like no but i think what happened was
i had told some girl on the phone and
segura said well that's [ __ ] up and
the wait didn't hit him
until that podcast when he was on that
podcast he was like yeah man you told me
on the phone and i didn't really
understand it
and he goes and i think that's what joe
was going through is he heard it but he
didn't understand it
and then two days later he's like wait
that was really [ __ ] up and so
it was a really really weird situation
and it's weird situation when you live
your life out on podcasts out in the
open like that yeah where you're like
you're like you roll the dice am i gonna
become a meme
you know like right like what the [ __ ]
yeah it was it was dude the thing that
sucked about it is a month
for all of sober october my serotonin
levels were off and so i was like going
through hardcore depression
and anxiety also october so i didn't
even get to
enjoy sobriety the way i had in the past
i never felt i felt at unease because
you're rolling so hard or so guys no
because
you know i think when you do molly i
think i i don't know
but i'm assuming it borrows good energy
and flood your head with that
and then the next couple weeks you gotta
rebuild that good energy
like it takes from tomorrow and so i had
anxiety attacks throughout the entire
month
are you are you an already 100 now or is
it like 92
no we're fine he's i mean
how's he doing i don't know i haven't
talked to him in a little while he's
he's
not so good i haven't talked to him i
mean i
look i told him i said this definitely
changes a lot of things you never
allowed my house again
my wife hates him to death my wife my
kids
my kids [ __ ] hate him like they yeah
what sucks sucks is isla loved him
island him connected on so many things
they're both weirdo brains
and i loved him and then she saw me
texting him
i was at my sister's house she saw me
texting him and she goes
uh why would you text him and i went oh
baby
it's complicated she goes it's not
complicated she goes dad
he almost killed my dad and i went huh
she goes
how would you feel if i was texting
someone who drugged me and i went
oh my god i would not like it and she
went right grabbed my phone and i went
oh [ __ ] she said and i told sorry when
he did it
you just [ __ ] everything up man like
you're never gonna be allowed in my
house again
and that's what made me so upset as i go
and he just
he you know i mean we've talked on the
phone we've talked a few couple times i
haven't really seen him
um you know the kobe stuff went down i
texted him a couple times i called him
that monday you know and talked to him a
little bit
but uh but you know it's it's
complicated but you know i
i think that i'm if anything i'm very
capable of forgiving people
may be too capable right good he was
scheduled to tape a new netflix special
right did that just go away
yeah um yeah it went away well it was
it was he was paying for it himself i
don't know if netflix had bought it yet
but he was paying for it for himself and
i
not to speak too out of school once
again but i think it was just a
liability issue
of the people working on there were a
little nervous there were death threats
but but it sounded like it sounded like
the tickets were sold people were still
i think he ended up doing the shows the
shows were awesome you know i don't
think i don't think cancel culture
i think it only applies when you let it
apply i guess because i don't think
anything's really changing for him
he didn't have any tour dates he was
done his tour you know he's doing shows
in new york no one's
approaching him no one's seems to be
right i mean
i don't think he's going to be hosting
america's got talent
but he seems to be doing fine and kind
of oblivious to the
you know he stayed offline so he was
really oblivious to the backlash
like he just stayed offline and i was
like i was like i was like wow
i checked it out a couple times right
good call
did you see the god free video [ __ ] off
coffee
that's like not a guy you ever see like
that uh no
i've never seen grandparents like that
godfrey was really upset
uh brian cowan was really upset michael
rappaport michael ravaport
is beyond upset right callan was pretty
measured about
it like there's no god was measured kel
was measured on the podcast
oh gotcha i talked to him the day before
it was it was it was a super tricky
situation to be put in as his friend
right of course it took people because
did roger ever acknowledge it publicly
no no but and i think that was the
wisest thing anyone did
is because it's really hard in that
moment to say
hey this guy is not the villain right
because he did do something that
everyone sees is hateful
but he's going i know a different guy
than that and
it was it was just super complicated so
even this he'll watch this they'll get
upset
with me about talking about because i
won't frame it i'm sure he'll be
upset with me and and i mean whatever
like i felt the way i felt i'm honest
about what my future
i think i think you should be honest you
should be able to respect that and i and
and i told him i said man it's hard it's
a hard thing to talk about and
your people are gonna ask me to talk
about i don't know what to say man you
know i mean dude i don't want anybody to
be
like [ __ ] vilified ruined like
forever
like you know i'm not i don't subscribe
to that yeah and uh
so there there it is yeah yeah but uh
the molly jones but i'm allowed at birds
my wife i happen to be there right now
so [ __ ]
much you have no idea yeah i mean oh
i went right when it happened i went
back
i took my wife i walked already out i
took my wife into the bathroom
with my cousin andrew and i said i'm
gonna tell you something and i need you
not to have a motion about it
she was like that's not fair i go no
you need to just shut it down and she
said okay i said ari slipped me molly
this woman i haven't seen her mad like
that ever
and but what really sucked is no one
took care of me in that moment like i
was like
i'm the one that's [ __ ] scared and
she was so
she went okay what do you need for me i
need to get out of the house
i need i'm going not to say goodbye to
the girls i need to get the [ __ ] out of
here and i'm going to go to the store
and i'm going to wait for my flight
there and i'm going to go drink she went
okay
i said i need you to get me packed and
she was like deal
packed me got me in a car service gave
me a kiss and by pact it means like a
toothbrush
and a backpacking blood pressure
medicine
i went to the store the first person i
saw was david spade oh
david spade's like how you doing i said
i've been mollied and he was like huh
and then ari walked in the same room and
he's like are something bali stop being
a [ __ ] about it and i'm like
it was so [ __ ] it was such a [ __ ] up
night
everything about it like i'm on the
plane just blowing up going like walking
up and down the aisle like
hey anyone want to party you know it was
just it was it was
insane it was [ __ ] so crazy because
i've been sober
since before they'd started calling it
molly
i think yeah
i guess molly is the pure the ecstasy we
used to get was just
basically amphetamines and i think
that's
basic basically but molly uh man the new
molly's not that bad
at what point did it start feeling good
immediately
yeah well what panic set in when he when
he said to me he goes uh
i said are you on something cause he was
acting weird he was i don't know are you
on something i went
no and he goes are you sure and i went
yeah i'm sure ari and he goes okay
i'm gonna tell you something and you
cannot be mad about it i know what all
right he goes
you're on molly and i went what he was i
slept you molly are you subju molly so
it's already happened i go did you talk
to my cardiologist about this and he was
like
excuse me i said i'm on blood pressure
medicine already
i mean this might kill me anyway i
didn't think about that
i go i go well hold on i gotta get on a
plane tonight and he was like oh i
didn't realize that either
he's like okay well my kids are here i
didn't think anything any of this
through
but it's already happened and i was
[ __ ]
i i initially had a panic attack so i
was like i was like
oh my god i am feeling this like this is
what i've been feeling
and i thought i was just having like
little flighty anxieties and i was like
oh [ __ ] i'm on molly and then i started
freaking out my cousin andrew
i randomly walked up i loved my cousin
andrew sat next to me
and i started rubbing his back and i
felt a lot better and then joey diaz
came over
and once joey diaz got there i was like
i was like god damn he's so beautiful
like the sun was backlit and i could see
the the fleas and i saw ari's eyes are
really pretty and i was like
holy [ __ ] i was like this is [ __ ]
awesome but i also in the moment was
like
i was well aware of the repercussions of
this i was like
you are my friend and now you have
[ __ ] up
us being friends forever because my wife
will not let you at my house
i will never be able to defend going on
vacation with you again
my wife won't there's certain things
where my wife's like why would you do
that
my daughters are now gonna hate you the
worst part is like a month later
my daughters come we're all sitting at
the table and we're talking about it
and my daughter isla walks by my wife's
like hey let's drop it we got ears in
the room and ella goes no i know what
happened
and we were like what george and i came
in we have friends she's like yeah
kids at school talk about it i said what
she would say the kids at school
know what told me what happened i said
what'd they tell you and they go
what happened that ari uh roofied you
and raped you i was like whoa he didn't
rape me she was like yeah yeah he raped
you right i was like no he didn't rape
me
my other daughter's like no sometimes
dad when you've been roofied you don't
know you've been raped
no one [ __ ] and i'm like you guys are
walking around thinking i got raped in
my backyard
like what [ __ ] what cool kids i got
ramped and they didn't even bring it up
and then i go he didn't break me and
they're like why didn't he rape you i
was like
why would he rape me and they're like
why would he drug you he's not gonna
rape you i'm like no one raped
anyone
what what greater than i don't know
tenth grade and eighth grade now but i
think they were yeah
but it was it was just such a [ __ ] up
scenario but then
that's the weird part is that you know
you live this life out in the public
like this
just gonna come back you know it's like
what the [ __ ] well let's go do some
molly yeah
i'm good i don't know where you go from
there dude i'd say we [ __ ]
it might be a perfect ending yeah like
can i tell you the best part can i tell
you the best part of this joke
that's the best part of the story my
wife still [ __ ] livid still [ __ ]
livid
and my daughters go how much molly did
ari give you
and i go he gave me half molly and our
friends are at the table
and my daughter goes why would someone
give you half a molly
and leanne leans forward in the in the
for i by the way i haven't laughed about
this event yet
i had not one i haven't found any part
of this funny i haven't laughed about
the
entire incident yet leanne leans forward
in a perfect teaching moment
she goes he gave him half of molly
because he's jewish
[Laughter]
i cried laughing and they're like wait
what does that mean i go don't worry
about it your mom just made me laugh
we're good we're good i'm gonna get
through this
because he's chewing that's hilarious oh
that's so that's the perfect way to end
that's good oh my god i love you
yeah dude